hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
ich habe letztens eine coole funktion
auf meinem iphone gefunden und zwar
heißt es tastatur vorschläge hört sich
sehr blöd an aber ist tatsächlich
irgendwie cool hielt deswegen seht ihr
jetzt hier auch einfach mal auf der
rechten seite meine notizen app vom
iphone eingeblendet und zwar ist es dort
ja ich glaube am besten ist es wenn ich
zeige wie ich es mache wir geben hier
erst mal kurz die überschrift ein
irgendwie kommt öfter buch und jetzt
seht ihr ja schon das über der tastatur
verschiedene sachen vorgegeben sind wie
beispielsweise ich die oder das und
damit schreiben wir jetzt quasi ein buch
das als video habe ich jetzt nur noch
neben zwei gesehen und es ist noch
aufgefallen als irgendwie den abend
feiern waren und ich drücke die ganze
zeit da drauf hat den text geschrieben
von wegen ich habe mir ein auto gekauft
und wieder verkauft und keine ahnung der
kampf all die lustigen sachen raus ich
weiß allerdings auch nicht ob es witzig
ist wenn ihr euch das jetzt anschauen
aber ich würde sagen wir fangen einfach
mal an mit ich habe ein neues auto da
kommt immer irgendwas mit auto ich habe
ein neues auto gekauft und die anderen
beiden seiten der registrierung in der
stadt und land was die anderen beiden
seiten der regierung in der stadt und
land wir fangen jetzt einen neuen satz
an und zwar die frage ist doch wie so
wird jetzt nicht nur vorgeschlagen oder
so die frage ist doch nicht nur die
frage
die frage ist doch nicht nur die frage
das buch ist derzeitig jetzt schon
besser als bei minecraft bundesstaaten
den nächsten satz jetzt einfach mal mit
nem das ist ein test der
zeitschrift für wirtschaftlich krank das
ist ein test der zeitschrift
wirtschaftsrecht alles glasklar als da
die nächsten satz starten jetzt einfach
wieder mit ich habe dich lieb und teuer
ja ich hab dich lieb und teuer
ich habe es mir nicht vorstellen können
ich habe mich in münchen können richtig
lieb und teuer
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich jetzt
einfach auch mal du eingeben kann genau
ok düsseldorf ist das nicht mehr
düsseldorf ist das nicht mehr ich fange
jetzt einfach mal an mit kann ich nicht
mehr zu sehen sein
düsseldorf ist das leider nicht mehr da
kann ich nicht mehr zu sehen sein kommen
wir versuchen jetzt mal ansatz zu bilden
der so richtig lange es aber auch in
sich schlüssig aufgebaut ist der mann
ist ein sehr guter zeitvertreib für
zwischendurch
der mann ist ein sehr guter zeitvertreib
für zwischendurch einfach eingabe
widerrufen sind dass ich mich öffne kaka
der mann ist ein sehr guter zeitvertreib
für zwischendurch und ich bin ein star
die frage der ehre für den hinweis
darauf dass ist ein test der stiftung
bad
ich bin auf dem weg der besserung ich
für reine schmolz alter die frage der
ehre für den hinweis darauf hin das ist
ein test der stiftung warentest ok danke
für diese info hat ein schwarzes blut
ich fand das einfach mal an mit ich
schreibe dir eine mail mit dem thema der
diskussion über die bühne und die
anderen beiden seiten eher britisch dazu
kommt noch eine frage der zeit
ich fange jetzt einfach mal mit kraft
ist ein schöner abend mit dem auto mein
vater hat mir schon mal ein paar wochen
nach der schule
warum kommt jetzt nicht irgendein werk
oder so mein vater hat mir schon mal ein
paar wochen nach der schule zu hause ist
also apple die könnte daran noch ein
bisschen arbeit um das ganze videos mal
so ein bisschen zu ende zu bringen mache
ich jetzt als letzten satz schreibt mir
mal bitte in die kommentare ob ich das
richtig verstanden habe und ob es
funktioniert nicht richtig ist
und dann kommt noch mal eingabe
widerrufen wahrscheinlich meine dass ich
hoffe euch das video irgendwie ein
bisschen gefallen meine damen und herren
wir sind da nicht eigentlich damen und
herren das ist total fertig und uncool
mir ist auf jeden fall spaß macht ich
bin halt auf die idee gekommen weil ich
das bei einer freundin gemacht hat und
wir uns da irgendwelche komischen
geschichten überlegt hat wie das war
vielleicht gut für den video idee ich
wollte hier unbedingt mal machen ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob es cool war
plötzlich war ich denke paar witzige
sachen dabei ein paar war noch eher so
apple
what the [ __ ] you stay trotzdem freue
ich mich über jede art der bewertung und
schreibt immer die kommentare ich das
richtig verstanden habe und ob es
funktioniert nicht richtig ist tschüss